there's no one's insight to Australia's
deadly wildfires this morning the fire
danger is increasing along with the
temperatures which are expected to hit
record highs the fires have burned more
than 12 million acres more than in any
year here in the US since the 1950s
Teagan George of our partners at Network
10 in Australia is in the coastal town
of Marin gula where thousands of people
have been told to evacuate we're in a
town on the south coast of New South
Wales and the smoke is incredibly thick
you might be able to see it it looks
like snow falling that's actually ash
it's been falling all day it's just
making it incredibly difficult and at
times painful to breathe it's stinging
the eyes conditions are growing
increasingly worse here in New South
Wales thousands of people have been
evacuated across three states as some
200 bush fires continue to rage the
death toll has now exceeded 20 also
difficult Lee for many people some 500
homes have burnt to the ground Australia
though has welcomed the support of the
United States some 40 US firefighters
have arrived here to help battle these
deadly blazes the Australian military
the Army and the Navy have also been
deployed to help evacuate people in
coastal towns that are surrounded by
fire we're now in the danger zone we've
had record-breaking temperatures the
winds are picking up and conditions are
actually right for fires to merge to
create monster fires so the next 12 to
24 hours is going to be critical for CBS
this morning Saturday Tegan George
Marie Mueller Australia just never
ending and you even not just the people
you hear about the animal species and
worry of extinction with so many they
believe are gone
you